okay hello everyone we are looking at
some of language design about an old
subject at least for philosophers
ontology
so let's take a look here so this is
about we're talking about hierarchical
entities is that correct
yes or more precisely we want to attach
properties to subsets of existing
entities and we do that by introducing
new types which are tile types of the
existing entity types
let me see if I understand this so
we've got right now a species entity
type
but now
what we want to do walk me through this
yes so so the upcoming upgrade of
species called taxonomic species for the
moment will have various child types
virus for instance or even further down
an animal no and
um do we get to even toad ungulates at
some point
or you know do we get to mammals
that would be a question for the species
developers yeah no not at the moment
okay I mean that's what we hope to do
because we expect different things for
you know fishes and whatever we'll
expect different properties won't we
this is what we went through before
right
yes
but but but
there are some members that have
properties for non-membles
like wingspans maybe like bats yeah
okay
but I think that
there are plenty of
I understand that point we talked about
that before yeah
um
uh
I
well okay maybe I should look at this I
mean this is more more about the the
framework and the idea not about the
concrete breakdown for a given domain
okay fair enough but I thought what we'd
agreed was
that while it is the case that you know
an astronaut could have a notable
artwork
that
we were planning you know we break
things down like this person is an
example of an astronaut they're also a
person that person could also be a
something else
I I don't know how quite how to think
about this because you know a bat is not
a bird
but maybe a bad is a flyer
yeah yeah yeah
so yeah so so the idea that we had last
time was that we have two types of
parent types of a given type one is the
entity Source type which is where the
entities are coming from and the meeting
should be about this entity Source type
now and then we also proposed having
additional parent types which we call
the property Source types okay which are
types which only give additional that's
a good idea that's a good idea so in the
case of the Tree of Life The Entity
Source type is basically the taxonomic
tree
the taxonomic species yeah no no but I
mean by that that then we do have
mammals we do have whatever right
mammals are part of anime you know of
animals Animalia whatever
we don't have a problem then with that
even though there are mammals with with
wings
because then what you're saying is the
property Source type would be that a bat
could get bird-like properties in some
way
am I making sense
yeah so so there could be a property
Source type of winged things like planes
and birds and some entities can have it
from that
I should just say so different from the
The Entity Source type which will be
restricted to
the
I mean in a sense
it's not even entity it's really
taxonomic Source type and I mean
taxonomy in a more General sense than
just animal you know just biological
it's somehow well I'm not sure let's
let's go through what you're talking
about here
so so the first idea is to introduce a
new symbol entity type we had a way to
refer to entity types before we just
used entity with one argument yeah so so
having a dedicated symbol is a little
bit cleaner in my opinion because there
are some non-trivial properties I
thought we had a query entity type for
just random things how do we extract The
Entity type of a um
uh of something no if if you have an
entity we can apply entity type name to
it but it just Returns the string so now
this would be a better representation
yet to encapsulate the string
so wait a second if I have just a
generic oops if I have a generic uh
thing that I'm asking about like a um
like a bat for example
um
by the way the fact that there is in
this magnified view the fact that
there's this asymmetric space really
bothers me
and we should make sure that that's
recorded as a bug okay so what is the
thing here you're saying it's an entity
type
property
we have a symbol called entity type name
oh entity type
so yeah I see
okay so we had reserved I think we did
that intentionally we had reserved the
notion of entity type
so we can do that we could we can call
this entity type an entity type name
becomes analogous to common name for
example yes
okay
all right okay so the next type wrapper
and that gives this and and then this
that's the question how do we represent
the child types so if you want to hover
over one of those entity types under
vertex list yeah there you can see the
input form
the idea is to have a sequence of rules
that is basically scoping the animal
under species
yes
well but now I don't understand here
we've got eukaryote goes to animal oh
yeah we've got you carrot right here
I see why don't we not have prokaryote
going to bacteria
and that's a species
okay go here
no
yeah yeah so there's no a specific
um taxonomic rank oh
yeah above like bacteria virus
um yeah
other than uh top level organism I
understand but a bacterium is a
prokaryote yeah that's right but uh
there is no like official uh taxonomic
uh I think it's called probably super
Kingdom rank
and there is nothing beyond that
okay so in other words it's
inconsistently done even though
bacterium is a prokaryote it's the only
it's it's not like this case where there
are multiple
uh what are these what's Animalia what
is that what is it called it's a
Kingdom isn't it the Animalia is a
kingdom and this is this a super kingdom
here that's right yeah
and so bacteria don't have a super
Kingdom even though they are in fact
prokaryotes which could be their super
Kingdom but it doesn't identified that
way so is that a correct statement oh so
virus and so on super Kingdom ah
categories
oh these viruses the super kingdom yes
yeah okay all right fine there's some
biological Turtle here
um okay all right so let's keep going
here so this is
um
so so this is also proposed type setting
for those entity types
quite nice
yeah okay
and and they have certain properties uh
for instance um The Entity Source type
of every type yeah hold on one second
here one second I mean these things are
always trees right The Entity graphs are
always trees correct
they're not Dags
in our case they are trees yes as long
as we don't introduce property Source
types then we get tax
so for for the moment we have trees
correct
okay okay
but I mean you know for for our trees we
have very clear
accessories for the different you know
parts of a tree and children of of nodes
and things like this right
so I'm just saying we should make sure
we use those oh you have a tree right
here yes so for the taxonomic species we
could get that tree and do whatever we
like with it so that's an example just
below the tree map it shows okay you're
on top of this basically
all right so hold on hold on so this is
I'm confused here why is there not a
thing called entity type tree or is that
why is it a child type tree yes uh I
wanted to make sure that it's clear that
we don't go up maybe this is implicit no
what do you mean we don't go up
give in the UK yes we only go down from
there
for which for the entity I mean like
like if I do for the other books
okay but if I take this thing here
and I say to this
you know
entity type graph
that's really weird
it's it's just because layout is not the
idea
yeah so so the graph is the same you get
basically the connected component
of the whole entity type graph in which
this type exists
okay so so the graph layout has been
fixed already yeah yeah okay fine
and
just
I'm confused I mean these are these are
standard names and these are common
names here was that yeah so this has
been fixed it's okay according to
production yeah okay
um
okay all right so there's a graph
and the graph goes both up and down
and there's a tree that for reasons
you're perhaps going to explain only
goes down
is that correct so so we omit uh the
property Source types then we have them
in the future or if we have them in the
future so it's clear that we only go
down
I'm sorry wait a minute property Source
types
they also come down but they would be
hanging further up and point to any
Target in this graph
I see so fungus that had wings
would have a
a thing from
uh okay
okay I get it
so
I mean the canonicalization of the
property Source types is non-trivial I
mean like for example how many property
Source types do we think we'll have
four species
a hundred
I think this fuel
okay
and
what kinds of things will they be
because I mean like like
a fish presumably
has
you know most fish have I don't know
number of fins things like this right
but so do whales but how do we do that
because mostly that's a fish property we
don't want to extract from fish
and make them you know make their fins
have to come from some Thin thing
property bucket
does that make sense yeah
but somehow we want to inherit
from fish I mean the best thing seems to
me is
there's a thing that's usually an
attribute of fish
but in fact we want to inherit it first
citations
as opposed to going up and saying
I mean I I just think that otherwise
we're going to have an untethered
you know craziness of you know oh
because of the Platypus okay look here's
the case where here's why this can't
work okay
in you know darkest wherever Peru
whatever the
um you know there is discovered the new
species of whatever it is of of mammal
that in fact has I don't know what you
know it doesn't lay eggs it does I don't
know what it has some crazy property
right and then we say oh my gosh we
can't have the gestation period
for mammals because look there's a
mammal just been discovered that has
you know I'll give you another example
better example perhaps
let's say we have a notion of um I don't
know multiplicative star systems or
something
and then suddenly something is
discovered which is some continuous
swirling you know thing that doesn't
have a
multiplicity we can't now blow up
everything in that entity type
and say oh that has to come from some
super entity type
just making sense sure I see what you
mean
right and so I think it's much better to
just say that we essentially because
that is what commonly people do is they
foreign inherit a fish notion for whales
and things
right we borrow a property from a an
entity type that didn't naturally have
it
comments
I think otherwise we're going to have a
ridiculous mess of you know well we have
things which have you know wings but
they don't have the same kind of wings
they're really webbed wings and they're
webbed feet as well and they're this and
that and you know
for properties we have something like we
have includes regular properties and we
have extra properties that we can attach
to any level we needed
to anywhere from anywhere but we have
we have uh imported properties we could
even call them that come from a
different entity type
they might or they might not even come
from a different entity type they are
just so unique they don't exist anywhere
yeah I mean I I
the way the way I would think about it
but this is given the framework that we
have now which maybe you don't like is
um two things first of all there was the
previous discussion of bats where
there's where
there's things that can fly
and mammals and you get the union of
those properties but then you might say
oh but then there's something even more
special about bats because
um their wings form a membrane or
something yeah and so and so then then
you know this might be exposed or it
might be just a implementation detail
but bat is itself its own entity type
and so it can have additional properties
beyond the ones that it just gets from
inheritance well but
which is in fact a bat's plural because
like for example you know the frequency
of their echolocation or something like
that it's probably different between
different species of bats yep and it's
something we'd like to be able to record
now that's a good idea to basically have
the possibility of attaching properties
yeah it will never be needed yeah so
hold on we've got entity types we've got
entity classes we've got entities
presumably bats here is an entity class
is that true or what is that thing what
is that anyway
this would be an entity in the previous
species
but in the new world it's probably some
some named level of the of the tree this
is correct
yeah so it could be in the taxonomic um
one of the attacks are in attack Sonic 3
or Bots actually can be uh so-called
species pilotic group so we have like
something like fish like beer those are
not official
um Parkinson in taxonomics reader
because their species belong to multiple
branches in taxonomic three so we call
those other like phyletic group
so if you clearly for example uh species
phyletic group of fish you can actually
get the list of of fish species
okay but hold on go ahead
I think you can form a practical point
of view when one's two things for a
given entity type one wants to know what
are the properties that these things
have and then for a complete thing one
wants to know all quantitative or
qualitative properties the things have
and there might be
there might be some missing for whatever
reason because they don't apply and
there might be some additional ones
okay but I want to point out something
okay so
so there are cases where
okay something like bats are different
from something like astronauts
because
why are they different
astronauts are all well give or take
people
okay
and somehow they that is merely a tag
whereas a bat
I mean I understand you could say it's
an animal and it's just tagged as a bat
I don't think that's how you think about
it
the most important quality of the thing
is that it's a bat
I feel like this is a slippery slope
because like I I see your point for us
to announce but maybe use a different
properties of humans say they are
of a certain skin color they are of a
certain height
and then become nearer in the example to
this but I still think we shouldn't do
it this way
well okay but there's a look
I guess one point about it is one one
difference is if you're a bat you'll
never become going to become a frog
whereas if you're an astronaut you could
become a painter
now you might argue that
you know there are attributes of people
that you can't change
you know other things who can't change
like stars like becomes a super giant
becomes a dwarf whatever
sorry what do you mean you mean it can
uh the the star which is currently
tagged as a as a red giant yeah well one
day become a neutron star yeah
it's a different time scale but the
problem is still there
well hold on the the thing you're saying
okay
I mean that's of course a total mess
because let's imagine I don't think it
happens but it when it goes Supernova
the star breaks into two pieces yeah
maybe that's the first question right no
it cannot be I mean one of them when
it's going off at
0.2 times the speed of light tooling off
to the other side of the Galaxy no I
think that there are two new entities
they have a certain property something
like where they come from and this is
the old one which goes away
yeah in time
right I mean you know and there are
horrific cases here of you know plants
that send out Runners and another tree
comes up and you know it's uh I mean not
that we probably have famous trees
famous individual trees we have famous
organisms of other types I think we have
a couple of famous trees okay they're
not exposed in language yet but there
are a couple of famous trees okay
right I mean but but that means that the
notion of what's an individual there is
such a mess
I feel like is a very common thing that
we that if I totally agree but I feel
that this is also good knowledge to this
discussion like when is an entity in
abstract things versus a very concrete
thing
like in this sense human embeds are the
probably the biggest differences
a class of things even a concrete
sub genus of a bad it's still a class of
things where a human is really just one
copy
well so people say what about the
Neanderthals
I mean no no the human in the sense of
person he means like you or yeah
individuals yeah individuals right right
right right right yeah
a few other entity types I was just
working on this actually in my
post-arastatelian efforts of um
yes I mean there are singulars like that
they're a named singular things like
that
and then there are things which are
categories of thing
and I agree those are different
this is not represented in the ontology
I feel like right now at all
which we're talking about
if it's one concrete item or a class of
things
right so I suspect we're going to need
that in other words it's a singular it
is the Eiffel Tower
right it's not
I mean relatively straightforward
because virtually
all entity types that are now with
inter-type all entities of this type are
easily love and all their classes I
agree I agree so I mean
if it's suspension bridges or something
there can be you know the Golden Gate
Bridge that's a singular
it's also you know a bat named Fred or
something is a singular which happens to
be
yeah so I think there are these Notions
and and then by the way to extend that
notion there's also something like
tungsten which I'm just going to say
this yes right that's a that's a third
there are actually five cases as I
recall that I could identify because
those are of concrete kinds of things
they're also abstract kinds of things
am I making sense that uh
um
yeah generic physical object specific
physical object
physical substance
generic abstract object specific
abstract object abstract concept
I believe those are the cases
so like a generic abstract object to
something like a story or a task
a specific abstract object would be
something like the number seven
and an abstract concept is something
like heat or time
so we've got generic physical objects
specific physical object physical
substance
physical substance being these things
which are
you know extensible where we are dealing
with the aggregate the of the thing
actually I do I do think about you know
a field of sunflowers
that's
a weird case because
well you're also
hmm interesting okay in anything it's
really a different story from today yeah
I think so okay
um
all right let's look at today's stuff
okay so I mean I'm again what we're
saying is
there is a notion
what you're identifying today is a
hierarchical collection of mutually
exclusive
entity types
is that a fast statement
not the mutual exclusive that might be
true and species but in other cases
a person can be a musician and astronaut
so then it's
a tree of types
but a given entity could be of multiple
types is that what you're saying yes
so for species The Entity counts should
sum up when you go up the tree from the
bottom
yeah
okay but
I'm sorry I'm I'm looping back on this
thing again about how to deal with
properties
I mean we have both Linguistics and okay
so you know my general view of how this
is going to work
and as I've been starting to think about
this kind of Post-Star statelian stuff
um
what we're going to end up with are
small calculi of things
that is
you know
if we know that we will not
what am I trying to say
certain properties and things will have
certain little calculate associated with
them as in
what's a good example
um
you'll be able to deduce things from one
property or from a combination of two
properties if the thing if the thing has
a trivial thing okay if the thing is a
you know live birth animal it'll have a
gestation period
that's what I'm saying yeah yeah
and um yeah basically what uh we saw
very clearly in
in the topological spaces where we have
so many properties and there's this
three then a certain other one follows
yes no I mean are we good to get
examples of other
I mean there are other
calculate for example a building can't
be destroyed before it was created
for instance probably maybe that isn't
even true it's really a calculus or is
this just a set of restrictions on the
property values I think it's a calculus
because I think there are much more
complicated cases
in other words those are the cases that
are kind of trivial but I think in the
end
there are
um
you know for instance in the case of
time we have intervals of time we're
going to end up with temporal logic type
stuff
of this thing you know
this war happened at this point and it
was over this time span and it started
you know before this one started but the
other one went on longer and so on and
there'll be somewhat non-trivial things
to untangle there
I mean I I think most of the time that
the
okay here's what I expect
I expect that at the beginning
most of these calculi will be fairly
trivial
okay
just as syllogistic Logic for Aristotle
was fairly trivial
but that once we have all these
calculating encoded
then we start being able to build much
taller towers as one could with more
Boolean type logic
on the basis of these things once those
things are solid
then you can build bigger towers with
them
that makes sense
yep
but we've never had a situation where
those things are solid I mean the best
you know people have encoded some of
those kinds of things but they've always
been
uh and you know
some
I mean
the issue is what things will be
robustly true about the world in the
same kind of way that logical inference
is true about the world and there
certainly are things that physics has
shown us are true about the world as
robustly and we can build fairly big
towers so anyway that's that's okay back
to this but but
I'm still concerned about
this notion of of essentially entity
hierarchy
as distinct from property hierarchy
and there are certain cases like the
tree of life is one case
where there's a pretty well defined
entity hierarchy where are other places
chemistry we looked into it it's it's
very complicated but it's at least on
paperable well defined like if you're an
alkane then you're also this and you're
also that
is that what you mean Json as you can
probably elaborate much better than me
yes
okay
other examples
Geo things
Island continents
so you mean if you're an ADM one you
also have ADM twos inside you and things
or obviously if you are adm2 you are
definitely live in adm1
right the other direction might not be
yeah okay fine but I but is is that
really the same kind of relationship
I mean there's those are containers but
is a is every ADM too really necessarily
inheriting all the properties of the
I think it is because it's kind of like
it's it's entity
sort of containment by bureaucracy
if you're an ADM too yeah of this
country then you fly that flag
presumably
but now you're in additional Island then
it becomes interesting where where do
you get your property of being in the
island
not from that hierarchy I mean that
that's that's a topic yeah I mean
just like you get your property of being
winged not from being a mammal
so I mean I am not so so convinced about
this poverty hierarchy that's why I
think that should be maybe a little bit
looser
said
okay but but so hold on okay point one
this is a thing we learned you know more
than a decade ago about backbones for
things
you know okay first point is
there are categories of things like
buildings for example and yes you could
argue is that particular radio Mast a
building
but the first question is is that sort
of a backbone
in which something is canonically
considered a this or that
I would I would be slightly bigger not
canonically considered but people would
agree to
fine
now obviously we have situations in
which we are disambiguating it is
a
you know
I don't know I'm thinking of the
whatever it is the the
the whatever it is there's a ship that's
somewhere in Long Beach I think it's you
know it's a it's a museum now but it was
a ship right now it's a building
and there's also a certain kind of
context to it like
an element could be a chemical or it
could be a material it's a different
Viewpoint I know right so but look look
if what is reasonable is that it add
this ambiguation point
in entity identification
but you say do you want the Queen Mary
as it was as a ship running around the
ocean or do you want it as a museum
building and wherever it is
you see what I'm saying yeah and so long
as we feel okay about asking people to
disambiguate between those things those
can be different entities
I think they are in my opinion they are
different entities
even though in a ship of Theseus kind of
way
it's the same pieces of iron
that are
so your point is
okay so the basic point is our
operational definition is if we feel
okay asking people to disambiguate
between them
then they can be different entities
if people look at it and say I don't
know what why I would distinguish a
you know this or that
then we've got a problem
and I feel like the different entities
are defined through the properties like
the the properties of the Vasa right now
in Sweden is no longer its speed or how
many people work on the Cannons because
that's right now not what it's used for
but when it was
on the Baltic Sea in action this
worldwide relevant properties yeah
okay all right so Okay so we've got this
notion of an entity which could be
thesecially connected so to speak to
another entity
in other words that that is a possible
property of things is sort of related
entities
like they might even be stronger like
that's maybe not the most scientific
example but Pokemon like this goes into
this descriptive to this it become a new
entity but physically it clearly evolves
out of somebody else and it still has
the same okay atoms
the butterfly that comes from the
caterpillar
um
which
right okay fine so
you know so there's a notion of material
connection so to speak between two
entities yeah
all right but then
we've got
um
okay so we have the notion of entities
then but we also have these backbones of
entity hierarchies
for example let's take ships as an
example
isn't it the case
at least for warships that there's some
kind of hierarchy of types you know a
destroyer a frigate a
ship of a line or something I don't know
my my Naval History or whatever anybody
know what I'm talking about
I I know what you're talking about
but I feel like here it becomes a little
bit blurry when something is an entity
type because it's an entity class
then I would say the countries of Europe
form such a stronghold they should be on
type
I see because within because they have
all sorts of properties in common
because the EU and specifically they
have whatever exactly
um
okay
okay so what is this yeah they shouldn't
be an entity type no I realize right
right so what is the difference
an entity type
you know an animal versus a building
a species versus building okay what
about the tree house
you know that's made of well that's of a
singular of a singular tree
but
okay so there is a notion of of its you
know it's very essential
being I don't even remember didn't
didn't you know I've never been a big
fan of Aristotle but I seem to be thrust
back into his clutches now
didn't Aristotle have this you know
definition of causes right this the
formal cause the um the material cause
all these things anybody remember this
well I think he has this notion
of
um
and final cause which is kind of the the
teleological
what it's for type thing
but I think that's what we're going to
end up going to is something like that
where we have to say what is the thing
essentially that is going to be its
entity type
what is the thing I mean it won't be
quite the same as that but but
you know what is the thing essentially
it is a
it is an animal versus it is a chemical
versus whatever else
what is its sort of Core Essence then
interject yes but but say your example
from earlier of a famous tree
is it really essentially a famous tree
or is it essentially just an oak
foreign
okay so what we're doing there is we're
crossing the singulars versus generics
right
right and I I feel like essentially it's
always a generic per definition
I agree but I think it's going to be
necessary for us to have you know a city
is always a city
but
I think it's okay
well we may yet be burnt by this
but the notion of a an animal versus a
famous animal that's a notable animal
I would argue that
hmm
well I mean this is like famous diamonds
well famous gems same story right we've
got the gemstone Emerald whatever it is
and then we've got a famous Emerald
so we're always Crossing
in some cases like gemstones we're more
often going to be talking about the
generic but we could talk about the
famous
in the case of cities
at the present time
there really is you know cities are sort
of generic as in it isn't the case that
like for example
let's imagine the contract cities are
individual
no I understand that I understand that
but what I'm saying is there is no
useful okay it isn't the case
let's imagine that there were
uh
I don't know what what they might be I
mean very
um let's think
is where people live versus cities where
where you know horses live or something
there were two types of cities two
completely distinct types of cities
which there are not
let's give a better example let's say
um
yeah okay let's take Bridges okay there
are
distinct types of bridges which like
bats could have their own
generic entity types a suspension bridge
a whatever type of bridge whatever and
many of those things come with a ton of
properties that are specific to that
type
but in the case of bridges both things
are relevant
it's a suspension bridge versus a
what is another kind pylon bridge I
don't know what they're called what are
they called Help
um
yes arched Bridge whatever it is
the uh
right so that's a case where there is a
specific Bridge a singular Bridge versus
generic bridge and those are both useful
entity types just like they are for gems
with famous gems animals with famous
animals and so on
so in a sense we have a this specific
generic thing
is something where we could double up
for essentially every
every entity type could double up in
that way some we know are doubled up
others we don't know are doubled up I
mean in the case
what's that batteries
there are many entity types very concept
I wouldn't count on that okay I wouldn't
count on it you know one day when
there's a super battery that is you know
the powers
California when everything else I who
knows what I see
um maybe maybe you're right so I I
really tricked but there might be for
even for mundane objects
certain ones that very famous people use
or the first light bulb or something
like this
exactly yeah
so I mean I think what we're concluding
is
there is just like your super Kingdoms
in biological species there is sort of a
super entity
concept
which is is it a singular or is it a
generic
now
I mean I'm sort of influenced because I
do know that in the sort of
philosophical literature those things
are they're just those two types
discussed it's not like there's a uh you
know that's singular there's Pairs and
there's generics type thing or something
but you know who knows whether that's
actually correct
in
I mean like like for example let me let
me be really difficult okay the um
uh
let's say we've got some ducklings
and there's a uh you know the seven
ducklings I'm sure there's a
Disney thing with that or something
and the generic of the seven ducklings
not generic it isn't generic it's a a
singular brood of ducklings
but then also the individual ducklings
have their own personalities
that made sense yeah so in other words
we've got both the generic of it's a
duckling
and
we potentially got
we would argue perhaps a duckling class
of the ducklings that were came from
gemina puzzle Puddle Duck or something
or whatever the names are
um
and uh
and then we've got the specific of
you know
you know Jane the duckling or whatever
um
but coming back to the concrete
Authority at hand so if we go back to
the ones that we looked at it assume we
had now the famous animals in my opinion
the famous animals live in a tree that's
totally disconnected from this one and
they have properties that connect them
with each other but the famous anime is
not a tiny substrate that goes somewhere
off at I don't know which level probably
members or animals
no I think it's an orthogonal thing this
question of singular versus generic is
orthogonal to this hierarchy
yes but but we still have an entity type
of famous animals so it would live
somewhere it just lives in a it's
basically it's not the set of all entity
types doesn't form a tripod Forest
yeah
well but I I think one could say that
there is a projection from the generic
to the specific and from the specific to
the generic
to this there is a entity hierarchy
and then there is a specific generic
not hierarchy but but Direction
that's orthogonal to The Entity
hierarchy
but but if the famous
this is an entity type it's in some
sense not just also you know it lives in
the same plate
wait a minute what are you saying I mean
I understand that what I'm suggesting is
that if we take taxonomic species
okay every one of these is going to be
generic
then we have a notable member of a
taxonomic species
entity type of taxonomic species nope
nope okay
just just in the forest yeah and
connected by a particular property
connection that is
the specific specialization of you know
specialization the singularization of
that versus the genericization of that
that's exactly what that meant yeah okay
and the same with people not just the
other weird famous organisms the same
kind of case right people is also
another tree like thing which fits into
astronauts positions whatever and it has
no Edge connecting it to animal
it has auto connection but on the edge
in this Untold tree
I'm sorry why is the tree why is the
people thing other than it's a person
and they could be a physician or an
astronaut or both
I'm I'm confused here so it wasn't the
question yeah why I I thought they can
be I'm confused but what does the tree
do you have one of these trees for
people
you said okay what we've said is that
there are always said
is that there are backbone situations of
which you've mentioned chemicals Geo
whatevers geo-administrative Geo things
uh you know
species these have backbone entity
entity hierarchies
right in a way that
that perhaps
Bridges do not have a backbone
I'm thinking um
famous Bluetooth
well singular bridges yeah
right to any singular
yes in the Geo case those things are
singulars right yeah
and they have a hierarchy
we don't have the
engineering right so we don't have a
concept like or one place
as entity
which could be a city account but we
could have a concept of lakes the
absolutely different kinds of lakes
yeah
but that's
we could have that but it will be
completely separated correct from I mean
the singulars have their own hierarchy
and it's defined by you know who
collects taxes in this place versus that
place and and so on and so on and so on
it's an administrative type thing yeah
it's completely separate from whether
it is a
you know whether whether it's a habitat
of or whatever they're called um oh my
gosh what are those called things called
the zones
yeah yeah yeah right whatever it is you
know whether it's a it's a completely
separate thing it has its own hierarchy
which is defined administratively so to
speak as opposed to defined
I mean it isn't the case that the
breaking of the tree of life is
administered at the breaking of the tree
of life is sort of morphological and
genetic
It Is by its nature rather than by how I
don't know that's a funny distinction
but okay but let's
when there's any way I can mention in
all these Concepts
yeah but I mean I'm saying there are
cases where there is a clear
conventional entity hierarchy
okay those places are worth us modeling
an effect
Then There Are Places where we'd have to
make it up which I think are different
now
in the places where there's an entity
hierarchy there are also entity classes
and I would have thought that an entry
class
could simply be a collection of entities
independent of an
on the same type
what's that all of the same type yes
but I don't think that there is a
hierarchy within entity classes
I don't think there needs to be that
concept
I think that here's why
because we're dealing with finite set
theory by the time we're dealing with
entity classes
it's like an entity class is this and
this and this it's the countries in the
EU and it's the countries in the World
Health Organization or whatever else
maybe not quite as easy because we have
implicit entity clauses
like
you mean like countries elements with a
density less than 10
comes per cubic centimeter or clearly a
subclass of all with identity less than
15 ohms per cubic centimeter
okay but no no I understand that but my
whole point is any entity class explicit
or implicit is resolvable for a finite
set of entities is that a true statement
yes
so then all of the set theoretic finite
set theoretic kinds of things can be
done and we can you know it might be as
an efficiency hack we might do it
differently but but conceptually an
entity class is simply a finite set of
entities
as long as we don't introduce the
integrals as entities here on Save
clients
what about chemicals
that's what we well that's exactly what
we distinguished several years ago when
we invented molecule that molecule is
the analog of integer but chemical is
the somebody cared enough about it to
give it a name type thing
yes
and that that's similar to
this pile of you know this outgrowth of
rock is notable enough that somebody
called it a mountain
as opposed to it it's just a Geo feature
of the Earth
so I think that's pretty reasonable in
other words
the question
in a sense so a claim I would make is
any entity that should be identified as
an entity must have a name
if it doesn't have a name
it doesn't count as an entity I would
claim so in other words
if it doesn't have a a singular name
it doesn't count as an entity so for
example a particular geopoint
specified by lat long is not an entity
unless it also has a name
like null island or something
or the North Pole
does that make sense to people
yep
um I would say reluctantly yes I think
for our entities in the system yes for
entities say
that are in custom entity store say all
the traffic
signs in a city they they'll still find
it they don't have a name yet they are
still individual entities interesting
point
let's consider that for a second
they may have some kind of ID anyway
right which will be the standard name
finally
yeah they presumably would have an ID in
a database they'll end up having an ID
yeah
all right so it's the tagged wolves so
to speak yeah exactly
maybe I talked about name a little bit
too little
right they have an identifier
as opposed to things whose only
I mean okay when we say an identifier
it's like a uuid you pluck it out of the
bucket of a large number of identifiers
and hand it to this thing as opposed to
it is
essentially found from a coordinate
system or something
okay here's a sort of an operational
definition the name has a certain
arbitrariness to it
it is not a name that is given because
it is utterly systematic I mean I don't
know it reminds me of you know
King
Henry the 18th or something who has
given the even then there's some
arbitrariness to it it's it was a sign
that ID for it was not assigned the ID
because it was at this geolocation it
was assigned the ID because that was the
next ID that came up
I'm thinking about this because
it's like in the Library of Congress
catalog
isn't it the case is it the case
that in addition to the call number are
all books assigned an ID or are they
just given a call number which is their
category
I do not know does Ben know oh no no
isbns isbns are the equivalent right
that's the point
that's the point the ISBN is the ID and
it is essentially an arbitrarily
assigned ID
so that's a that's it's you know so it
has a canonical name
okay in any case all right Okay so we've
got the we've got these Notions
and any types for generic Center types
for cingulars
entity classes finite sets
then we've got this notion of
hierarchies
within entity types
where we have kind of backbone
hierarchies
and then we have
sort of
properties that can be imported from one
and we have this notion which we haven't
really discussed fully of properties
that can be imported from one entity
type and used on another
I'm not convinced about this spot
honestly
because like assume you need an exotic
one
and there's no other one yet out there
which has it then you have to recreate
it and you import it from yourself but
it's only this one entity within the
entity type that needs it
yeah that's right that's funky that's
funky but but I mean
that's also
well I used to think that this generic
month and special ones
generic and Watsons that the Elizabeth
arbitrary the vast majority of entities
in this entity type has has a complete
value for this property
that's fine then we know those are the
properties associated with that entity
that's what we've expected before you
but then it
properties that that can just be
that of course must be keptic and
normalized as much as possible but they
don't have to be
coming from somewhere else
I see what you're saying
look as a practical matter though with
our Linguistics and things like that we
want to get fin Linguistics from the
fishes
how would we get the fin Linguistics
we're talking about citations
certainly in our human way of talking
about it
we're going to use fish Linguistics to
talk about whales
yes
now I admit that these analogies are a
little weird I mean in other words
that's sort of an analogy
but but but modular technicalities of
implementation if we know that a certain
entity has
a fin property
we can kind of transport it to the
parcel and tell them if this entity
comes along but normally this type
doesn't have fins for this one it's fine
sure yeah I understand but I'm just
saying to organize it
I'm just saying that I think
see otherwise let me point out the
following thing so let's say we're
documenting this right we've got
the I don't know mammal
entity type it's got documenting all
kinds of stuff
you know it's gestation period it's it's
body temperature it's this that and the
other okay
and then we're like but what about you
know nobody expected the whale
and then we're sort of free form
introducing fin properties and things
like this
no I physically every
but there were some properties that of
interest that you didn't expect
I agree I agree but I'm saying okay fair
enough that point but I'm saying
wouldn't it be better if there is a more
structured source for those properties
like
it's fish-like
so we can bank and Port so we can at
least know
I mean in other words the calculus of
fins whatever it might be
okay I don't know what the calculus
offends is but it's probably you know I
don't know how interesting the calculus
offends is
um
the calculus of wings might be more
non-trivial about you know beats per
second and things like this lift and Etc
et cetera Etc
okay
much better that we can import that
thing from the birds
along with its calculus
then that we have to erect a new ones
specifically for mammals for bats
agreed but I was more thinking say on
humans we are potentially you have a
vast array of very special properties
that you can't import from anywhere all
right let's talk about that for a second
let's talk about the human's case
so
you're saying different occupations and
Things No I was more thinking
say most people are famous because they
did something very concrete that nobody
else did so per definition they have a
unique property
yeah
like that's only basically LinkedIn we
would associate by publishing slavery in
the U.S there's not many other people
who will get this or where should this
come from
right
but is that a property
I think every property value can always
be dual rephrase of having the property
value
as a property
but I would claim
that
I would claim that's not a useful
property I mean the property
of
well okay let's take another let's take
another property founders of
universities
of which you know Jefferson makes it you
know I don't know if John Harvard makes
it but but I don't know exactly how that
works but but you know
is that a property or is that something
else
because there are there are a a number
of them right it's not
although every one of those things has
mean does a person have the property
universities founded
it's a property of the University that
it's founded by yeah but then it's it's
some kind of person yeah but but then
the reverse should also be so you're
saying you could only implicitly look it
up
that it's the university founder but but
we could talk about if we have to have
properties on both sides for everything
that could be implicitly looked up then
that seems right but imagine that the
the crew of Apollo 10 or something
we've got an astronaut and they were
part of the crew of Apollo 10 and Gemini
six or something
but then we've also got that spacecraft
Apollo 10 and it has certain crew
members
I think in some cases that reciprocal
relationship makes sense in other cases
pretty tenuous
although the references on each side of
that might be slightly different like
you might have Associated you know space
missions on the person side which just
points to the mission but the mission
would have things like specific roles of
the people who were
part of the mission
why wouldn't that be also that person
was the commander of this Mission why
wouldn't that be somehow associated with
the person
like in the leader data how do you yeah
how do you want to represent that data
though you want to
have space probably you're right that
it's organization first that is that the
that it is the country that has a
president and that president is this
person and so on
but then what are you saying you're
saying
this person was an official of such and
such a country or something
and then if you want to know what
official you have to go back and
implicitly figure that out from the
country is that your idea
it's a little weird
entities right
I mean there are you can try to hang all
of the different attributes and details
on both sides but I'm just not sure no
I'm not sure it makes sense but I mean
and then and then maybe it's there's a
canonical side for certain things
but okay let's go back to the people
example so what what are you saying here
you're saying there is a
yeah I'm not saying it's a practical
thing but theoretically I could imagine
that all the things people are famous
for is a property rather than the
property value of what am I being famous
for
okay I think that's hopeless in other
words I think the only things
that should be probably remember
that our primary structure is entity
property value right
so for example universities founded
nothing universities founded three you
know different universities
saying
so there are properties whose values are
Boolean
you know we tend to talk about you know
cause of death or something and then we
have those could be themselves entities
I think I think we don't have a
disagreement and I totally gives you
that when there are
certain sets of properties in one domain
that apply to reasonable subsets of
another entity type we should of course
bike
transplant them but there will always be
thinking cases that we must take from
somewhere else
poverties
okay I understand so your point is
there is
let's take
I don't know the boroughs of New York
which I think is a nasty case right
because other cities don't have that
that subdivision Alan would probably
know
I don't know am I right in that that
being an unusual case
foreign
I am not certain it's Unique but it is
definitely problematic
right okay so that's so that's an
example so we've got for New York we
have to have boroughs and we have to
have a list of them
but for the
you know
200 000 other cities in the world they
don't have boroughs
that's a good example that's exactly
what I hadn't met right
how do we deal with that
I I personally would have a problem if
basically
there are generic properties and
properties that only apply to certain
things
okay so so then the concept would be
within the city
entity type
there is a list of properties that are
the generic properties that we expect
that most cities will have a population
a location those kinds of things
right and then we might have this this
bucket of special properties that we
expect to apply to only a small subset
of these entities
and you could look up the whole bucket
of all special properties which would
include the burrows for that case it
would include the the strange yurt City
that moves from one place to another
during the year or something
those kinds of things I mean that's a
little bit like
you have a manifold you have a you have
a three dimension and manifold in R6 you
can always embed it into some Oblivion
by witness embedding theorem in some
sufficiently how you delete it it's just
relatively pointless so we could always
pet
the generic ones with all the specific
ones that have missing not applicable
but it's pointless no no I know but yeah
why wouldn't we instead just introduce a
subtype right just extend the tree and
have a cities with Burrows
because I think that's going to be a
mess because I think it might have
Burrows and it might be a yurt City that
moves every season
and there's no reason to think so in
other words what would be a a property a
meta property of an entity would be what
properties it has
exactly
and it would then have its General
properties
and
it's um
and it's special properties I think
that's a pretty good solution actually
and and candidate right now you can use
properties and ask for properties of
entity type you get a generic one you
can use properties for a concrete one
and we can then in the future return the
union of generic and specials yeah
I think this is reasonable I mean I just
want to emphasize
some objections yeah I'm I'm not I'm I'm
thinking about how things are
implemented now and this seems like a
complete explosion on the database side
okay that's the difference of how the
database tables look I understand that
what I would recommend for that
I don't know what I would recommend
subtables are a possibility
subtables for every special in other
words that each
one of the it has some kind of foreign
key mechanism and each
entity points to certain sub databases
that are databases for every special
property
and well
and well by saying that we have the um
that we have cities with Burrows and and
you have the option of seeing that
anything can have Burrows or you can
insist that it's only cities that have
boroughs
okay let's I think this is a separate I
don't think this is a big you know I I I
see this I see the issue but I don't
think it's a huge problem but I think
it's not relevant to what we're talking
about here I think we've got bigger
philosophical problems to solve and the
question how we deal with foreign keys
in the database and things seems small
compared to this
I think we you know okay a Meta Meta
comment about the whole thing
you know this is something for which we
are trying to model the world and the
world is not it's it's never going to
have
Perfection we're going to end up with
things which are compromises and I think
this idea of backbones of entity types
together with
well now wait a minute is
is an astronaut as opposed to a painter
are those entity types
yes
they would be child type of person
exactly they're not hierarchical
no they're not it's it's a mess
and the point is that something that
that
um Everybody every person is a person
and then they can also be one or more of
I don't think that's going to work I
don't think it's going to work I think
that there are entities
where there's a strict hierarchy of
entity types that word that works too I
know that's one case but the case where
of
people
where the person is both an astronaut
and a painter
isn't
you know we're not going to say they
have a primary entity type that's a
disaster
so I'm not understanding how we deal
with that so that's actually the design
if you want to continue in The Notebook
but yeah
so
so that way you see entities it has a
new a special property called entity
type list where you can see all the
types and entities participating in and
it can be different for every entity
and because of that every entity can
have a different list of properties
so you're saying a given entity can be
can have multiple entity types
yes
which was one of the things you
originally wanted with this project
that will be similar to have this
concept of property buckets right
somehow
foreign
this concept of having different
properties attached to which entity
different groups or buckets of
properties yes
per definition the ones that are
inherited from the given entity
model type
types sorry I got distracted by
something could you say that again
please
so Francisco was saying that
the given entity that belongs to
multiple entity types the properties
come naturally grouped
from the inheritance from the types that
they come from yes
um
okay
well okay so
what's all this
so just to see the syntax of the new
entity properties if you'll see if you
go on the wingspan for instance and
hover over it you also see the rule like
syntax to indicate that it's an animal
property
okay so it's the same as for entity type
and here you can also see that if you go
down in the child type so by the way in
this setup
to have one of our special and
properties
could be something done in this
hierarchy
yes but you you could in principle have
a very small type which provides this
those additional properties which
contains just one entity that's fine
well or you could have a a wild card
special
I'm not sure what the right way to do
that is I'm not sure what the right way
is go go ahead you're going to say yeah
and you can see in this tree the numbers
indicate the number of properties that
you have and you can see that as you go
down you get more and more properties
because each type inherits the
properties from above for instance every
animal has a scientific name I got it
yeah
that's nice
yeah and further down we have some
examples from the species domain given
by kaiko
so so it's just showing that there the
new species and the neutology feature is
showing off so it's really powerful what
can be done
because the properties for animal don't
mix into viruses and vice versa
by the way that should be formatted a
little bit differently I think
so the great comments this is the
so-called sub-label yeah it should be
just smaller I think
okay
that's a very interesting case of a
um of a calculus the calculus of who
eats who
good example
of where there's a slightly non-trivial
calculation that could be done
I'm just I'm just trying to understand
I'm telling you the thing we're going to
find which is the generic story of
wolfen alpha is you know we're going to
find these small calculi and eventually
they will merge together into bigger
things
anyway that's just a minor point
okay so what
I mean predators
clearly it's only a carnivorous thing
that is a predator presumably
but we're not we we think enough
creatures are carnivores that it's okay
to have a what does it eat what species
does it eat so to speak as a generic
property
that makes sense
yeah
as opposed to
you know something where we specialize
down to koalas the eucalyptus spark or
something and ask which kind of bark
does it eat
which will only be true of a small
number of creatures
that's cool
oh boy
hmm
maximum speed maximum speed in the air
maximum speed running along like an
ostrich or something
what is the maximum speed
is it the maximum flying speed or is it
what is it uh it's a general speed
including flying speed and a lot of
clothing speed everything here we have a
separate property just as for example
swimming speed on flying speed okay I
see because otherwise otherwise you
could have maximum speed and then you'll
be trying to it's flight capable like
it's an ostrich but it could take off so
to speak
yeah
which will be very confusing
sorry I didn't get this one one more
time ostriches generically I mean they
run I I don't know exactly but they run
right but they don't fly
but that's why we saw people saying we
only wanted the one that were capable of
writing I I understand that I understand
that so but I'm saying that imagine a
bird
which I don't think exists that is
really a fast runner on land
okay but it also flies
and you see its maximum speed 20 miles
an hour
all right so you have no idea I see what
you mean
so the entity store
the design is analogous to entity
classes
foreign
[Music]
this is a new proposal so this can be
nested so what exists or what has
existed till now is that we can have
entities properties entity classes and
so on for each type and now a new entry
comes along called entity types
so it's just parallel to all the others
yeah and you can Nest them I'm the
musician you could have a piano player
and so on
I think we need to do another iteration
of all this stuff I think we need to see
I mean the thing you've implemented here
we got the generics and singulars we've
got the the
generics we identify them but we don't
have any encoding of this right now
right
all right I think we need to wrap here
um we've done our real-time Philosophy
for the day
um
yeah please this was good guys this is
good I mean real progress thank you and
I'm glad yes thank you Tony is back and
doing this as um okay so thanks and see
you soon
bye for now